I'm back yes I still work here for those
of you don't know I went away on a
lovely holiday for about five weeks to
Europe went to Germany Switzerland
Sweden
met Peter this guy who works for me I
guess on Hazel got some uh fun videos
coming up
with Peter anyway point being I'm back
now I'm back in the office this is the
studio Channel official headquarters I
guess in Melbourne Australia and as one
does after he returns from a holiday I
realize that I need to really rapidly
get back to work and catch up with
everything and more importantly it is
definitely time for us to release the
next version of Hazel so for those of
you a little bit out of the loop we
released
hazel2023.1 there's a video up there I
never know which corner that video goes
over all of the kind of major features
that were in that release at this point
in time this kind of big professional
version of Hazel however you want to
call it is only available to patreon
supporters that's how we fund the
development of Hazel it wasn't for the
supporters we would not have Hazel would
not be at this stage whatsoever because
I wouldn't be working on it full-time
neither would Peter but if you take a
look at when that video was released
well it was a while ago it was a while
ago and I believe the original timeline
for
hazel2023.2 was like June or something I
think we wanted to do it quarterly uh
and it's September
and it's still not out so I figured that
I have no idea what's going on because I
haven't been in the office for like
probably six to seven weeks now I
certainly haven't been keeping up with
hazel and the rest of the team and
seeing what they've been doing and we
need to get this release out the window
so I figured I would kind of document
this process take you guys along with me
because I have no idea what I'm doing
this was probably a good kind of
opportunity to show how on Earth we go
from not having anything at the moment
or me not knowing anything to actually
having a full-on release tested you know
qaid out the window and I guess a video
published and everyone notified that hey
we have a new kind of stable version of
Hazel so that's what this video is enjoy
so this is what I like to call the the
cherno's three steps to success or
rather cherno's three steps to like get
a product released first step is
consolidation which just means like
tying everything that you want released
together AKA reach out to the team go
through any of your like local changes
or fixes or anything that's not
committed make a list of everything that
needs to be merged into like a staging
or a release Branch for testing once
you've got all of that figured out
testing slash QA so going through
everything making sure that we run
through all of our like test cases test
scenes everything works the engine
doesn't crash that kind of stuff and
then finally three is release which
doesn't just mean releasing the actual
like software and the actual product but
it also means going through and writing
up all the documentation for it so like
the change log and any other Associated
feature documentation that you might
need for an actual
release you know whenever people hear
that I'm making my own game engine and
they they're kind of following along and
they're considering maybe making their
own they always ask whether or not math
is important to make a game engine now I
usually always flat out just say Yes
um because I I mean I think it is but
the whole kind of subject of whether or
not math is important for programmers
like I don't know I feel like you could
talk hours about that because it's just
so specific to what you are doing with
that programming language what you're
using that tool for and it's probably
honestly just a topic for a future video
but I did want to say that if you are
looking to elevate your math experience
then you can do that for free with the
sponsor of today's video brilliant.org
those of you who don't know
brilliant.org is an amazing website
filled with lots and lots of really high
quality courses on various stem topics
they've got some great computer science
stuff that you can use to kind of ease
into the whole kind of programming
mindset they'll help you think like a
programmer but then as I mentioned like
math brilliant is my favorite way to
learn math on the internet the reason
why is because all of their courses are
extremely visual and interactive like
what better way to learn math than just
by seeing it in front of you in a visual
way having these like widgets you can
play with getting quizzed after the
lessons to help you like retain that
information and the wide variety of
topics they cover everything from the
Everyday Math course which is there for
beginners to ease you into math all the
way through to like algebra linear
algebra calculus you know this stuff is
really really useful for game engines
and the fact that it's presented
visually you know you're making a game
engine you're making something that is
very Visual and so I think a lot of us
really are visual Learners and to see
this content presented in such a way is
just amazing and what's even more
amazing is that brilliant.org has a
30-day free trial so you can take a look
at their entire platform all of their
courses for free for 30 days and see if
you like it and if you do they'll be
nice enough to offer the first 200
people 20 off an annual membership just
go to brilliant.org the journo link will
be in the description below huge thank
you as always to brilliant.org for
sponsoring this video okay so what I
didn't quite share with you guys was
that I had a call with Xerox yesterday
AKA Jim he's one of our wonderful
volunteers is working on Hazel his
system is animation that's what he's
responsible for and you guys might
remember him from the animation in Hazel
video the story of Animation Hazel which
will be up there anyway I'm just
introducing all the characters as I go
along which by the way on the topic of
introducing the characters maybe I
should introduce the Hazel team properly
enjoy this cool animation so of course
over here at the top there's me the
Project Lead my biggest responsibility
is probably just overseeing the entire
project making sure that everyone's
working together nicely and all these
systems kind of fit together I think
that that's like because you know when
you have just a group of Engineers and
they all have their own ideas you know
you can't have them all build the engine
as if it was their own because more than
likely they're not gonna you know
synergize well they're not gonna like
have the same kind of code style have
the same ideas they're also not going to
have the same experience they wouldn't
have gone through the exact same path in
life that LED them to be like the
software engineer they are today so
that's probably my biggest
responsibility but then there's also the
renderer I'm the only one on the team at
the moment who just actively works on
the renderer so I'm in charge of that
system and then there's also some other
stuff like runtime and optimization and
well really anything that needs doing I
have to do obviously and then we have
Peter so Peter is a software engineer
who officially works for Studio Channel
he's basically in charge of two major
systems and that is the physics system
and scripting he's also a bit of a
generalist as you would expect from any
kind of small team but physics and
scripting are kind of has two major
systems and then we have the volunteers
so Jim and Jay have been around for a
long time I've put this kind of green
border around volunteers and an orange
border around Studio Channel just so
that's clear but yeah Jim and Jay they
both report to me Jim is also known as
Xerox he's mostly in charge of the
animation system he wrote it there's a
great video up there that talks about
how that kind of came to be and then Jay
wrote the entire audio engine for hazel
as well as a lot of the kind of I am
gooey UI style that we use in our tools
and then as our newest edition reporting
to Peter we have Emily and Emily has
basically come along fairly recently and
just added Linux support to Hazel so
we'll be talking about that in a future
video as well so that's the team that's
the current team as it stands at the
moment so hopefully now you know who all
of the characters are anyway yesterday
we had a bit of a catch up chat so I
know like what he's working on I can
actually see him logging tickets very
well in jira he's quite a professional
so I basically just made sure of a
couple of things first of all what work
he thinks is stable enough and ready for
release and he's told me that that stuff
has already been merged into the dev
Branch we have a kind of Dev branch
which is like a central in development
non-released kind of non-stable
potentially Branch where all of the
other people on the team can merge in
their future branches when they deem
them like acceptable for you know kind
of like widespread use for testing you
know throughout the whole team but it's
still kind of an internal branch in the
sense that like there are no guarantees
about its stability but our general
workflow for release is is that
everything from that Dev branch is kind
of you know ready for release minus
official kind of QA testing so you
shouldn't be merging stuff into Dev if
it's not stable or at least if you
haven't tested it that's what your own
kind of personal you know feature
branches or whatever are for so Jim's
already merged like a bunch of stuff
into Dev he's even recorded a bunch of
videos for me as to like what the
features are it's got a test scene that
I can explore as well so that's kind of
the first point of like what what is it
that we are releasing of his work and
what does he want kind of tested and
released here and then the second thing
was because remember at the start I said
two points I spent so long on point one
that I forgot that I said that but I did
I think let's rewind that so I basically
just made sure of a couple things so the
second point is how do we even test that
so because we are like what I like to
call an unofficial organization meaning
that like you know we're not like some
corporation that has a development
director and official kind of you know
harshly enforced corporate strategy for
software development we're pretty lacks
here like we're pretty loose we're
pretty chill and so because we are
ultimately the burden of like you know
QA testing falls on to us as a team we
don't have a dedicated QA division or
anything like that so it means that I
need to know as the kind of leader of
this project the work that you've done
and the system that you've kind of you
know built and all the new features like
how does that even work how do I even
test it how does the rest of the team
know that it's like stable and good to
go so that's kind of like a massive area
and that's something that we really need
to uh focus on I'm probably going to
make some videos about this coming up as
well because as a small team that is
obviously undertaking quite an ambitious
project like we we obviously want to
spend as less time as possible testing
stuff and more of the time on actually
developing new features and kind of
improving existing systems but there's
clearly no way around you know at least
two people on the team so we'll say me
as the pro Project Lead and then the
person who wrote the feature
understanding you know the breadth kind
of of that particular feature and how to
test it and how to basically validate
that it is in fact working as it's
supposed to because without that I can't
really release this next version of
Hazel because I don't know if the
feature that has been written is
actually working properly as is intended
and also that it's not going to like I
don't know bring down the engine in a
crash or something and reduce everyone's
kind of user experience anyway the
reason I'm in this camera angle by the
way is really because I've been looking
at Fork um I was going to get to that
eventually these devlogs are all over
the place as usual but you know looking
at kind of fork here Fork is a get
client by the way it's the one that I
happen to use it just easily lets me see
kind of every single commit that goes
into Hazel across like all of the
branches so I can kind of see what's
going on I can see what kind of stuff
has been integrated into Dev that's
really really important when it comes to
documenting the new features as well as
the changelog and also obviously the
prior kind of QA testing that needs to
go into it as well so 0x slash gym is
done Peta as well I've had a chat to him
he's mostly been working on fixers
because he's working on a massive new
kind of feature for Hazel and that's not
ready yet for this release so he's been
mostly kind of managing like the rest of
the team I guess while I've been away as
well as making sure that like certain
crashes and fixes get fixed Jay who is
our audio guy is also working on some
really really cool massive new tech
which we will discuss in future videos
for sure but that's also kind of not
ready for this release so nothing to
worry about there and then there's the
new renderer yeah renderer 2023 is
officially the name of that Branch
that's my thing that's me rewriting the
whole renderer that apparently hasn't
actually been released yet uh it feels
like it has because everyone has
basically been using that renderer 2023
Branch at least to some extent it's
almost become the new Dev it's always a
really really good sign of like
mismanagement when one of your feature
branches becomes like the new Mainline
Branch like that that's just gold what
am I doing anyway so that really needs
to be polished up and uh ship now the
good news is because people have been
using it so much and I'm pretty sure we
shipped the last lottom dare game on
that Branch we know that it's like
stable the new renderer is good uh you
know it's pretty much good to go but
there are just a few missing features
that I really should have finished but
haven't and that's just to do with like
some Physics I think visualization in
the level editor so like because I
rewrote the whole renderer it meant that
like we switched to a completely
different way of like writing render
passes and kind of organizing I guess
the render pipeline for our all of our
rendering and so part of that work was
bringing across every existing kind of
render pass or render feature that we
had into this new system and the way
that I kind of you know worked through
that is I prioritized the kind of
runtime features so that we could
actually ship that last game Jam game so
that meant that things like you know
just the visualization of physics
colliders and stuff in hazelnut the
editor that obviously wasn't seen as
important since that wouldn't make it
into the shipped product but I obviously
need to make sure that's kind of carried
cross into the you into the new release
because otherwise it's kind of a
regression it's kind of like us taking a
little bit of a step back it's like yes
we've got this new renderer it's much
better it's much faster but you're also
missing that feature that you like to
use so sorry and we want to avoid that
as much as possible so yeah as I
mentioned I had a bunch of stuff that I
had to finish up for the new renderer so
that's basically what I spent today on
just kind of going through everything
making sure that all the all the
renderer features worked and filling in
the blanks just going through everything
that I had pushed to the last minute
luckily there wasn't anything major like
whatsoever that needed to be done I kind
of knew this but it was just a case of
like bringing something to like 95 done
but then just not kind of pushing it all
the way to completion in retrospect of
course I wish that I had because it just
meant that I wouldn't have to worry
about this and because it had been so
long because it had been like two months
two or three months probably since the
last time I actually actively was
working on this I forgot a lot of it of
course I did and that's another reason
why it's better to just finish it
straight away in the first place because
if I had just done that then I mean
there's probably like two hours of work
actually left but it took me the whole
day because I had to spend time
remembering everything and so that's a
little Pro tip to you guys just push
yourself finish what you're doing and
then just relax don't be lazy I should
watch these videos myself